[Musik]
erstens sich dreidimensional dargestellt
die virtuelle welt tournee mit seiner
figur wohl mehr selber entspricht drin
ohne bewegte das ist erst das zweite ist
die welt ist assistent sei
unabhängig jetzt drin bin oder not und
die erwartungen irrsinnig geglichen
wieder woanders sind und drittens hat
zusammenhang mit realer welt das ist nur
der rein virtuelle welt war ein fantasie
der fantasie entspringt sondern es hat
den zugang zu realer welt eigentlich so
definiert
das heißt dass ich das abstract konzept
das ding oder das produkt wohnrechts
dann auch kaufen sondern sich einfach so
eines konzept wie internet
die meisten machen sondern chatroom oder
womit eine steuer und hat das für juli
und 1 juli und dann komme irgendwie
kommuniziere mit einer eher oder es
konzerte zum beispiel um das glaube ich
dass limitiert die vorstellung sehr
stark ich glaube das wird vielmehr in
einer ganz anders sie als beispiel als
humus realer welt gibt was aber eine
digitale version gibt und wo das reale
hus mit sensoren digitaler version
meldet wissen gott gott und wurden
vortex techniker zum beispiel wüssten wo
im realen und stylisches wechsel oder
reparieren und mit brille ohne geleitet
werden das loch bohren und was für das
diamond neue machen also also sachen
denke ich sind mit
aufwendigen aber man muss sagen
eigentlich alle spieler mitmachen
persönlichen tage oder bis letztlich vor
will man einfach gar nicht so genau
wissen wo das danone fertigung könnte
ich glaube große schritt ist sie vom
internet und nachher mit dem internet
oder das ist die große kunst alles
verändert hat und das ist für mich
eigentlich mehr ein ort ein anderer art
wie er mit dem netz interagieren jetzt
sind wir sehr auf die kleine bildschirm
und ausdrucken auf dem bildschirm
fokussiert und das ist genau das was
mittlerweile anders machen wird und die
idee dass wir das uns oberhand
irgendwo visueller ort und das mitmachen
als ausdruck finde ich grundsätzlich in
attraktive idee die möglichkeiten für
die interaktion startet ich glaube das
wird
ein wichtiger teil vom taxi verfilmt und
es wird ein ganz
spezielles volk oder sondern einfach
absurd und macht es so wie man heute
einfach im internet ist und sachen
gemacht
weil ich ist internet gar nicht in den
wald wo hat mit real wird also vom
internet oder fiel auf dem internet ist
real oder hatten bezug zum realen und
mit dem etwas wird auch so sie es wird
einfach möglichkeiten bieten mit der
repräsentation von der realen welt
interagieren wo man honig und es wird
jobs kam aus honig gibt es wird
kommunikations möglichkeiten
unterhaltungsmöglichkeiten gebe es noch
nicht gibt es wird auch mittels
einfacher sind als sie in eine innere
welten metaversum hoffentlich
afrikas in das alles so wie es im
internet gibt es bequemer sind im netz
machen als als reale welt oder schneller
oder einfacher unterhalten
das heißt das ist wahrscheinlich so aber
die hand immer noten körper aus fleisch
und blut besessen
doch das macht einfach alles hinfällig
es wird wahrscheinlich komplex aber es
wird wahrscheinlich nicht einfach sie in
sinnvoll ich wohne in der wohnung und
alle dort wo die honig generiert
kontrolliere ich so witzig und birgt
sicher es wird viel komplexer sieht
firma wo die verschiedenen systemen
bietet firma was uns blüht wortwahl des
vornamens glied wo drin wohnen alle
werdet sich irgendwie zum ballgewinn
genau wie dort geschieht und wer
kontrolliert das wird zwischen handlung
mit einem dort behandelt also das wird
wir hätten einfach nur wie extrem
komplizierte situation werde und wo
meine sonne steht die gesellschaftliche
diskussion war es okay ist und was nicht
okay ist
der begriff kommt erst mal wurde neil
stevens erstmals
begriff kreiert die männer
science-fiction-roman snow crash ethisch
sofort diskutieren
das ist ein zwei große unternehmen
weltweit globale unternehmen das
kontrollieren und damit auch der alltag
von ganzen hof stark kontrolliert also
disco beat literatur eigentlich so sitzt
der begriff gibt bevor waren und in der
realität wird es wahrscheinlich eine
komplexe musik werden oder es wird
natürlich so dass es bei großen
unternehmen ein großer teil werden bauer
und dementsprechend kontrollieren aber
ich glaube das wird durchaus auch
möglich sie dass eine kleinere
unternehmensbereich oder reden eher im
privaten also lied ohne kommerzielle
absicht dass die allen teilnehmern und
einem meters und irgendwie es auch
gemacht ohne
controller vor wenigen großen
unternehmen und das ist dann so gefragt
wie die verteilung ist natürlich high
note trittin wundern wie den staat
reagieren auf das und allenfalls
reglementiert